اتفقت السعوديه وايران على استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه واعاده فتح
السفارتين والممثليات الدبلوماسيه في غضون
شهرين وتم التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق عقب
مباحثات جرت في بيجين مسياقات التي دفعت
باتجاه التوصل لهذا الاتفاق كذلك اي دلاله
للاعلام من الصين عن الاتفاق من
الانعكاسات المنتظره لهذا الاتفاق على
الاقليم
[موسيقى]
عندما يجب ان تتذكر او نرجع للوراء لان
العاصمه العراقيه بغداد احتضنت خمسه جولات
من المباحثات والحوارات الامنيه بين ايران
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وبالتالي توصل
الجانبان الى نقاط في غايه الاهميه خمس
جولات كانت مهمه من اجل استكشاف المواقف
وكيف يمكن الاتجاه قدما الى اعاده
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين في
الحقيقه هنالك نقطتين اساسيين المملكه
كانت حافظها حينما قطعت العلاقه في عام
2016 تم الاعتداء على السفاره السعوديه
والقنصليه وهذا خرق لاتفاقيات فيينا
فالاجتماعات الامنيه السابقه والاستخباريه
التي تمت كان احد الاهداف منها التاكد من
ان الحكومه الايرانيه قادره على حمايه
المنشات الدبلوماسيه النقطه الثانيه
والمهمه ايضا السعوديه ارادت ان تتناقش في
كثير من القضايا التي تهم الطرفين لذلك
لاحظنا في البيان احترام السياده الخاصه
بالدول وهذه قضيه مهمه النقطه بالنسبه
للمملكه هي توازن العلاقات الاقليميه
والدوليه هي اعاده ترتيب علاقاتها مع
تركيا هي الان تعيد ترتيب العلاقه مع
ايران هي تبحث فيما يتعلق بسوريا وبالنسبه
لايران عانت بالفتره الماضيه من عزله وهذه
العزله كانت احد اسبابها الاساسيه على
العلاقه مع دول الجوار حينما تقدمت ايران
خطوه فبالتاكيد المملكه تقدمت خطوات ايضا
موازيه بهذا الاتجاه
[موسيقى]
الصين هي اكبر دوله اقتصاديه لها علاقه مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والدول الخليج
بشكل عام حجم التجاره الصينيه مع دول
الخليج لتجاوز ال 130 بليون دولار اكثر من
36% من احتياجات الصين للطاقه تاتي عبر
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ايضا هي الشريك
الاكبر لايران الاقتصادي حينما زار الرئيس
الصيني وكانت القمه الصينيه الخليجيه
العربيه السعوديه في الرياض في ديسمبر
طرحت قضيه ان ان على الصين ان تلعب دور في
المنطقه يختلف عن دورها التقليدي وهو
ابقاء المسافه المتوازيه والمتساويه ما
بين كل الاطراف بمعنى ان اذا كان الازمه
في اليمن هي بسبب الدعم الايراني للحوثيين
في اليمن فيجب على الصين ان تمارس ضغوطها
على ايران لكي يسود الامن والاستقرار في
منطقه هذه ولتلعب دور الضامن فيما يتعلق
بهذه القضايا
يعني اعتقد بان هناك الكثير من الدول
وشعوب هذه المنطقه سوف تكون مستفيده من
التقارب الايراني السعودي كل الدول وكل
الاطراف المنطقه وحتى خارج المنطقه رحبت
بهذا التقارب سواء كان العراق او سلطنه
عمان او الدول الخليجيه الدول الكبرى رحبت
هذا بالتاكيد اسرائيل لا تريد اي تقارب
اقليمي اقليمي
واسرائيل تريد التازيم تريد التقسيم تريد
تقسيم المقسم وتجزئه المجزا هذه العلاقه
واعادتها سوف يفتح الباب واسعا لمناقشه كل
القضايا اللي موجوده في المنطقه سواء
الامن البحري سواء امن الطاقه سواء
الميليشيات سواء حزب الله في لبنان الحوثي
في اليمن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فهذه كلها سوف تقود ان شاء الله الى وضع
افضل اولا خفض التصعيد المفاهمه المباشره
الحوار المباشر ما بين الطرفين ايران دوله
كبيره في هذه المنطقه والسعوديه ايضا دوله
كبيره في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي وصل الى
قناعه مشتركه وهو ان هذا التدافع لا يخدم
مصالح اي من البلدين في المملكه تفتح
ذراعيها مستعده اذا تقدمت ايران خطوه نحو
السلام والاستقرار في المنطقه في المملكه
ودول البقيه الدول الخليج مستعده ان تخطو
خطوات اكثر بكثير نحو هذا الاتجاه
[موسيقى]